>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Todd Harvey: Hi.
My name is Todd Harvey.
I am a curator at the
American Folklife Center
at the Library of Congress.
I'd like to welcome you
to the latest presentation
in our ongoing Benjamin
Botkin lecture series,
and this is what we call
an open mic session.
So it's a slightly different format.
The Botkin Series allows
us to highlight the work
of leading scholars in the
disciplines of folklore
at the musicology, oral history,
and cultural heritage while
enhancing the collections here
at the American Folklife Center.
For the center and the library,
the Botkin lectures
form an important facet
of our acquisitions activities.
Each lecture is videotaped
and becomes part
of the permanent collections
of the center.
In addition, the lectures
are later posted as webcasts
on the library's website where
they're available for viewing
to Internet patrons
throughout the world.
So, now would be a good time to
turn off your devices if you wish.
Today I have the honor of
introducing Jayme Stone
who with his band, just
gave an amazing concert
in the Coolidge Auditorium and
if you're looking at the webcast,
I think you need to go back
and look at the concert first,
because what I'm going to try to
do today is to bring some context
to that, to that event and to
help us and you all, you know,
I'm working on behalf
of you in the audience
to better understand what it's like
to be a touring [inaudible] musician
at this point in time, and also,
to better understand to style
that Jayme's bringing to
Library of Congress materials.
So, I just want to
say thank you Jayme.
That was a really amazing
performance.
>> Jayme Stone: Thank you.
I mean, it is such an
incredible honor to be
in this building always,
but especially to play.
I mean, I could you know like
you know, I've spent some time
down in the basement and
I could feel it you know,
there's that old saying you know
like we stand on the shoulders
of our elders and I felt that
quite literally, and you know,
on stage with an incredible history
of music here that's informed
this project in so many ways, so.
Yeah, it's definitely an honor.
>> Todd Harvey: Yeah, how did you
feel about the performance today?
>> Jayme Stone: It felt amazing.
Yeah. It was really nice.
You know, knowing you
know in the same vain
that you know the same space
that Alan Lomax recorded
"Jelly Roll Morton" and
you know the Josh White
and Golden Gate Quartet
record was made there.
So, it you know, it felt like
there was some history there
and also it's a point
in time in this project
where you know having been doing
this for the last about 5 years
or so, feels like the band
this season there's like a kind
of family-like chemistry.
I feel really, really proud of
this new record and the work
that we're doing and we're a little
bit like in that phase of touring
where we're kind of on fire because
we've been playing every night,
so it's kind of nice to be in
that particular phase and then get
to do you know a concert like this.
Yeah, it felt really good.
>> Todd Harvey: Well, yeah if I
could think of one word to sum it
up it was a "tight" performance
no doubt, and I'm just wondering,
where do you find musicians
like that?
>> Jayme Stone: Well, Toronto,
Vermont, and Nashville precisely.
And people often ask
us that, you know,
how in the world do you find
them and where did you meet them?
How do you rehearse and all
these, you know, questions spin
when we're hear where we're
from and it's really a testament
to these particular musicians.
All of whom I know
in different ways,
essentially through the very
tightknit group of, you know,
folk musicians who you know I
like people that have a foot
in the traditional camp, but
are also experienced doing a lot
of other music and have really
a wide ranging sensibilities
because that's what it takes
to you know treat the
material in the way that we do.
So, Moira Smiley, I was
given a record of hers
by a mutual friend probably
like more than 15 years ago,
and she in turn had heard
my music and when my wife
and I were getting married
we were trying to think
of like the absolute
perfect music and, of course,
it had to be just so, you know, and
I wanted it to be so many things
and she was somebody
that I was like,
okay we should get Moira Smiley.
I had never met her.
And so we looked on her
tour schedule and low
and behold she was
finishing a tour in Boulder
where I lived the day
before our wedding.
So it was a kind of serendipitous
meeting and we met on my wedding day
and we've been friends ever since,
and then when I first started
gathering together people for the,
you know, collaborator of the Lomax
Project, she was one of the first
that I thought of and we've
been playing music ever since
and Joe Phillips the bass
player, we've been playing
for almost 10 years together and
then we've done everything from work
with symphonies and chamber
ensembles, to playing you know music
from around the world and doing folk
traditions and so all of that is
in his playing and in our history.
And Sumaia Jackson is the person
who is newest to this group
and she's been doing all the touring
for the last 2 years and she was
at the Berkeley College of Music
in the American Roots Program.
That's an incredibly vibrant, very
forward thinking you know folk
and roots music kind
of breeding ground.
And I actually called up all
of my friends there and faculty
and I said, you know, I'm looking
for a fiddler you know who's the
perfect person for this project,
and they all without
having spoken before,
they all said Sumaia Jackson,
so, but that's them you know.
>> Todd Harvey: It's
really an exciting group,
and you mentioned being on tour;
I saw on your schedule you got
a tour next week every night
in California or something
like that, is this,
you've been touring
with this recording?
>> Jayme Stone: Yeah, yeah the new
record officially came out in April,
but we had them at the
beginning of the year and usually
as the record cycle goes, you know,
when a new album comes out we sort
of try and trapes, zigzag
around as much as we can.
So, you know, I have a family.
I've got 2 young kids, 3 and 7 so I
can't go out for really long tours.
So, you know, we're out
for something like a week
to 2 weeks a month which is a good
amount in the first, you know,
6 or 9 months of a record being out
and then it can pare
down a little bit.
>> Todd Harvey: I took the
opportunity to look at some
of the videos that you made
with the Lomax Project and I,
this is kind of a second phase
to that and one of the comments
that musicians in that band
made over and over again was
that it was a joy to work with you
because you are a good band leader,
and I think that's worth
exploring a little bit.
What makes a good band leader?
>> Jayme Stone: That's
a good question.
I've done it for a longtime.
I think, you know, I started playing
banjo 22 years ago and very soon
after knew that I wanted
to play the banjo in a way
that didn't particularly exist,
and I wanted to make music
that combined things that were you
know not typically found together.
So, it was clear that I
wasn't going to get a call.
Like no one was going to say,
you know, come play bowed banjo
on my record or you know we
have this idea for a project
of West African music or, you know,
we want a chambers
symphony with banjo.
You know, so if I was
going to do the things
that you know were lighting up in
head I would have to create it.
And so I had been thinking for
a longtime how to cultivate
and create a context you know for
the things that I wanted to do
and that really involves
people and working with people,
and I love collaborating.
And, you know, what comes
to mind is actually a,
there's a beautiful movie
that Wim Wenders made
about Pina Bausch;
have you seen this?
She's an amazing choreographer and
she worked with the same company,
of course, people came in that,
but for many, many, many years
and she had this process where
she would essentially present
like prompts.
You know, she would say like you
know what does it, what does it look
like in your arms to you know be
a cactus or something like that?
Or things you know
related to whatever;
theme that she was beginning to
cultivate for a certain piece
of choreography and they
would move how, you know,
they felt like naturally
you know from that
and then she would make notes
or later photograph and film
and she would curate you know
their own personal language
and she had the big umbrella vision.
You know, and she was
the choreographer
but she really used their
voices or their bodies in a way.
And I remember being really
moved when I saw that film,
because it was something
I'd been trying to do
but maybe a little bit shyly
because I felt like, you know,
maybe I needed to be more
of a capital C composer
and you know write out all the parts
and you know and I've done some
of that, but what I find most
satisfying is to really find people
that have a singular way of
playing and that I resonate with
and create a process by which
they can really be themselves
and then I can kind of
go back in and figure
out like what works
together and shape it,
so I think of myself almost
as the curator of the music
or the arrangements
rather than sort of coming
in with a big monolithic decision.
>> Todd Harvey: So that
must necessitate a lot
of rehearsal time upfront,
is that true?
>> Jayme Stone: That's true.
I've also been working with people
I've known for a while, so you know,
you know musicians who are
steeped in all the things
that these musicians are you
know where they're improvisers
and they know traditional music and
they; we share a lot of references.
You know, I can say like oh yeah
you know we want this thing that's
like a Bobby McFerrin
circle song, you know.
And that can be like right, you
know, and when you work with people
that are cut from the same cloth or
you know you have a history with,
there's this shared language
and you'd be astonished
at how quick the process can be you
know with really great musicians.
And then there's the secondary
process where you then hone
and you know things get seasoned,
but a lot of times you know I've
become a bigger believer in like a,
you know, first thought/best
thought sometimes.
You know, like that arrangement
of "Old Paint" kind of came to,
it was the first thing that
we ever did with Tim O'Brien,
and Moira Smiley, and Margaret
Glaspy, and Greg Garrison.
And Margaret had brought in,
well actually there's this
really curious Lomax recording
where he's interviewing Vera Hall,
you know, from Livingston, Alabama
and he actually start, she
was such an phenomenal singer
that he started testing her to see
if she could back whatever
melodies you know he played her
or sang to her.
And so he actually played her a
recording of "Goodbye Old Paint"
which was not in repertoire, not a
song she did and she hummed it back,
you know and of course, like all
you know amazing musicians couldn't
help, but you know it
came out sounding like her
and it was actually that,
that little snippet for
25 seconds no words.
She just hummed the melody that
Margaret Glaspy used to kind
of rework the verse; she brought
that in and it just sort of happened
and around you know, I said well you
know, we can't leave out the chorus
in the whole part of the story
and so I wrote, you know,
the chords for this and then Tim
O'Brien kind of quickly pulled
out some songbook sand
got online and we sort
of collage together lyrics
from different places;
oh like that verse, I
don't like that verse
and then we just played it a
bunch and it just kind of happened
in a way out of thin air, you
know, just this community spirit
and that's, that's you know kind
of often times I think
where the magic happens.
>> Todd Harvey: I am curious
as I ask about rehearsal time,
about the mechanics of putting
out a record, touring it,
getting the musicians in the same
city at that same time and I noticed
that you, you do a little
bit of coaching right?
Some, is, can you tease that
out a little bit for us?
What are the economics like and how
can I become a touring musician?
>> Jayme Stone: Exactly.
Well, yeah the margins are slim.
You know, I have been you know
existing, orbiting in a world
of you know folk and
world music and people
that are you know making the music
that they really want to make,
you know, and following artistic
rather than popular choices.
I mean, I made instrumental
music only for a good longtime.
This is actually the first project
that has singing in
it for the most part.
>> Todd Harvey: And
you're singing as well.
>> Jayme Stone: And I'm singing
yeah that's a whole new thing,
but so anyway yeah the margins are
slim and you know that word you used
"organized" is really what's it's
all about and if I have a skill
as a band leader that's
a big part of it.
It's being very, very, very organize
especially when you're dealing
with busy musicians that are all
involved in lots or projects,
Cheryl was in orchestra for years.
Moira you know sings in 3 bands
and has her own solo career
and is a composer, and so you
know doing; I do my own booking
which is somewhat unusual.
I'm self-managed and do my own
booking and which is common
at a certain like grassrootsy level,
but you know for doing the kind
of stuff that we're doing these
days it's a little unusual.
So I have to be really organized
also just to maintain some semblance
of balance having a creative
life, you know, actually feeling
like I'm a musician and I'm
not just kind of sitting
at a computer sending emails
and having a family and all
of these things, so I you know
you can ask people that know me.
I don't usually waste a second.
You know, if there's like 3 minutes
between something I'll
just get something done,
and so yeah being organized.
I plan really far in advance
and that tends to be the way
to work with great musicians.
You know, because you can't
call up an amazing musician
and say I have a gig at the Library
of Congress next week,
are you available?
Because they're not.
But if you do it a year ahead or
longer, then it works out so, yeah.
>> Todd Harvey: And how does your
record label figure into this?
Are they helpful in
terms of booking and?
>> Jayme Stone: Yeah, they
don't do any booking stuff.
I'm currently with Borealis Records
who put out the Lomax Project
and this new Folklife record.
I released 6 records
independently before that.
So I'm used to just like
roll-up your sleeves, you know,
do it all yourself kind of mode.
So, I often am like steering
the ship, they're very helpful
and I have a nice little team,
but I'm often the one coming
in with ideas and energy,
but it's very nice these days
to have a support network and
they're a Canadian company
so they also have access
to some grants
which make the financial picture
really nice, because these days,
as people are streaming music
from out in the so-called Cloud
where musicians are paid
practically nothing;
the economics of making beautiful
records with 60-page liner notes
and multiple visits to the
Library of Congress for research
and you know it becomes rather
difficult and so you know,
part of the, part of the feat.
In a way, I actually feel like
you mentioned the coaching work
that I do.
I've been developing slowly
but surely an online course called
Compose Your Career to offer tools
for musicians, independent
musicians to kind of learn how
to make it work and, you
know, one of the things
for me is I actually
feel like your career is
like the ultimate improvisation,
because the stakes are high.
You know, I mean especially
as you get older
and if you're supporting a family
or like, you know, paying a mortgage
or whatever, and like on stage you
know you can reach for some idea
that you're hearing in your head
and if it doesn't work
out like it's gone.
I mean, maybe someone will
replay it on video, but you know,
nobody's going to get hurt,
you know, no one's going
to starve if you hit a wrong note.
But with your career it's like
it's a real thing to figure
out in the actual world which is
constantly changing and, you know,
the technology is changing,
and the medians are changing,
the whole business model and
what people like and don't like
and so it's a, it's quite,
quite a ship to steer.
>> Todd Harvey: So touring
is an important part of that
because of it's a paycheck, I mean?
>> Jayme Stone: Yeah.
And also you know, people love
to hear, experience live music
and as much as music has become
commodified in many ways,
in ways that I don't think
benefit artists many a time,
it's actually touring where
you're there in a room, alive,
making music there's something
very compelling and I think more
than ever these days, you know,
statistics seem to be continuing
to show that you know people
want to go see live music.
And so I'm thankful for
that and also that's,
that's where the whole
thing you know really,
that's where the magic happens.
>> Todd Harvey: I wonder who would
you think are your peers in terms
of folks doing the
same kinds of things?
>> Jayme Stone: Yeah.
Well, you know, many,
many of my friends.
You hundreds if not maybe a thousand
people that I know that are,
you know, out there doing this.
I mean people that I look up to
are like you know, Rhiannon Giddens
and Dom Flemons from the Carolina
Chocolate Drops who are, you know,
very successful making music that
I think is really important and,
yeah I can think of a lot of people
and I actually feel really blessed.
You know, I usually go to this
music conference called APAP,
and the Arts Presenter's Conference
in New York every January,
and I was there for a week,
a little longer than usual
and I only had one performance
and I got to spend a lot
of time just having informal
sessions making music with people.
I went out and saw music every
night and there was this incredible,
you know, hang after every show
where friends and you know heroes
of mine, you know,
were all just there.
You know, I went to go see Sam
Amidon who I'm a really big fan
of who does similar such work,
you know, bringing his own kind
of like indie pop production
sensibility to old folks songs
that he grew up with
in Vermont and heard
on field recordings
and that kind of thing.
And after, you know, the audience
was half like my favorite musicians
around New York and elsewhere and
there was this just amazing energy,
because it's like wow
these are our people,
like everybody's a little
bit crazy to be doing this
and also these are the people that
are actually doing it, you know.
And it's a, I feel very grateful
that I get to do it and that I get
to know people that are somehow able
to make this whole crazy thing work.
>> Todd Harvey: Yeah.
So, I am counting maybe 7 recordings
under your name going back
to a decade or so which is a pretty
good clip, and I think I recall
when we first met you
were working on a thing
with the Boulder Symphony.
I wonder if that was "Other Side
of the Air" which was 2013-2014?
>> Jayme Stone: Yeah.
>> Todd Harvey: Kind of recording?
What I'm interested in is how
your style has changed over time
or how the product has
changed and ultimately,
of course, where it's going?
But if we could go back
to that and contrast it
with the Lomax collection,
what was that recording
like "Other Side of the Air?
>> Jayme Stone: Yeah, so
that was a record I made much
of which were my own
original compositions
which is largely what I had done
before, although very influenced
by field recordings from
other places in the world.
So there's the first piece on that
record is called "Radio Wassoulou"
and I made a record called "African
Appalachia" in 2008 after traveling
to Mali and I made a bunch of
recordings as I traveled around
and kind of continued to use
those as a touchstone and so even
on that album there was 2 very
West African inspired pieces.
There's also a piece on there
called the "The Cinnamon Route"
that has influences from, you
know, North African music,
and Indian music, and Persian
music, and so I'm sort of pulling
in threads of music that I love and
listen to into my own original music
and then around the time I
was working on that, you know,
body of pieces a dear friend of mine
Andrew Downing who lives in Toronto
who is a fantastic composer
got asked to write a piece
for an orchestra that had a folk
element and so he just called me
and said, I want to write you
a banjo concerto, you game?
And I of course said yes.
So, we were trying to find
a home and you know things
in the classical world are you
know can take years before you can
actually get an orchestra to record
a piece and I was too impatient
and so I just said, well I'll
just put it on this other side
of this air record and then
with the Chamber Symphony there,
I decided that I would try and
score for the first time a bunch
of my own compositions
for Chamber ensemble,
and I felt completely
out of my depth.
And I remember, I remember actually
being in a hotel room in Rochester,
New York after playing at
Rochester Jazz Festival
and pulling open the music
notation software called Sibelius
with 17 empty staves and I'm,
you know, I'm a banjo player.
I can read music, but
very slowly and not well
and mostly everything's
by ear in my world.
And I was just like, and
I called my friend Andrew,
I'm like I really don't
think I can do this.
And he's like you can do
it just one note at a time.
And that was that.
I just sat there and I just
started writing, you know,
filling up the space in a
totally different kind of way
than the music that I usually made.
Anyway, this is getting longwinded,
but that record was what was
happening you know I was touring
actually when we started
the Lomax Project,
and in terms of connecting them
you know there's a thread that runs
through all of my work of taking old
recording and kind of finding a way
to make them newer using them,
you know, in the creative
and collaborative process,
and I had read
that John Szwed's amazing
biography, of "Alan Lomax;
The Man Who Recorded the World."
And of course I had been listening
to Lomax recordings for 22 years,
you know, since if first
started playing banjo and sort
of put those things together
like what would happen
if I took this kind of collaborative
process that I've honed in this way
of working with old recordings,
but then come full circle back
to you know the folk music that
I've always loved and played,
but have somewhat shied
away from on recording?
And so those were sort of the
ideas that seeded the project.
>> Todd Harvey: Is there any way
to tease out certain aspects of,
I mean you were talking
about your music, your style
and how would you describe
your style
and who may have influenced it?
I mean, when hear it
I'm thinking maybe
like John Zorn or Bill Frisell.
>> Jayme Stone: You got it.
>> Todd Harvey: Really?
>> Jayme Stone: Oh yeah.
John sort of less so, but
I you know I saw John Zorn
with his Masada Project in New
York probably 15 years ago.
And Bill Frisell was a
really big influence.
In fact, Bill Frisell was a
big influence like musically
and in terms of like looking
up to someone who had a career
that I thought was really happening.
Like, when I got into
Bill Frisell he was making
like a record a year solid;
a record a year and every one
of them you know, there was
"The Intercontinentals",
and "The Willies", and
the "East/West" Project
and you know he had a concept;
he kept drawing on many
of the same musicians, but always
bringing new people into the fold,
so there was a continuity
esthetically.
He had a singular voice and he was
able to sort of surround the way
that he plays even though it was
always evolving, but surround it
with you know new concepts and
players and projects and repertoire
and that record
"The Intercontinentals" was a huge
influence, in fact, I cried my eyes
out the first time I heard it.
I got an advance copy of it
from a friend of mine who worked
at a record store and I took it back
home and put it on, and it was like,
it was like that experience
of like hearing the music
that I had only imagined, you know,
I love Vinicius Cantuaria who's
a great Brazilian musician who's
on the record and I
had just been to Mali
and Sidiki Camara plays
calabash on that record
and there's songs written
for Boubacar Traore
who I had listened to,
you know, for years.
So, there was all these things.
It was like so inspiring.
And that idea that you know
what many of us know and love
about Bill Frisell it's
like what's he up to now?
You know, that think you know he's
coming to town and you think like,
I'm going to go to see him no matter
what's it's going to be great;
I wonder what he's
doing next you know?
And that actually became like you
know people don't love this word,
but like if there was like
a branding that I wanted
to have you know, my dream would
be when a music center would call
and be like we'd love to
have you at our festival,
like what are you up to next?
What are you doing now?
And sort of build a kind of trust
that, you know, there's good taste,
really great musicians, let's find
out where it's going to go next.
So, and I mean tons of
other influences, you know,
the thing about influences
is that nothing goes away.
You know, you're an
archivist you know it's
like the collection keeps
building and so you keep listening
and you keep having new experiences
and you play with new people,
you know, going to West Africa and
playing with West African musicians
for a number of years,
completely altered my playing.
And I think of the banjo, because
it is a West African instrument
that came here you know on
slave ships in the 16 and 1700s
and I really feel that continuity
and have studied not only
close ancestors of the banjo,
but also all different
African, you know, instruments
and so there are times you
know if I'm playing a piece
of Caribbean music where I
can quote rhythms and sounds
and you know palm mute the banjo
so it sounds like a thumb piano
or you know treat the instrument in
such a way or do things rhythmically
and I mean those things
don't go away.
You know, and it's one
thing to know the sort
of big guide posts
of style, you know.
I know how to make something
sound very much like African music
or Cajun music or something,
but it's the subtle things
that you can kind of pull in
without anyone quite noticing
and can cross-pollinate
all these different styles.
That's the stuff I'm
really interested in.
>> Todd Harvey: Right.
I was struck by what you said and we
should just get this out of the way,
right, that here we have heirloom
seeds and we're going to plant them
in new soil and see what
happens, and that is,
and that's a different
approach than a lot
of people would take
with our recordings.
There are the crowd of
people over there who want
to imitate precisely the
intonation and the performance style
as in Lomax performance style.
There's the crowd of
people over there
who will imitate it
but not very well.
And then there's people like
you who do something else
and I think they're all,
they're all fairly legitimate
and I only have a quibble with
one thing that you said there
and that is that the dusty
shelf, and I just have
to say our stacks are clean.
They're clean, it's the cleanest
place in the world you know,
and so if you can just
help us by pulling
that one out of your statement.
>> Jayme Stone: Yeah.
I'll go back with a
Sharpie and strike
that out of the line of notes.
>> Todd Harvey: Otherwise I find
no fault with what you were saying
>> Jayme Stone: Yeah, exactly.
>> Todd Harvey: A couple of
things that are still in my head
about your style and I think,
I think this is important
because you are doing
something kind of unique.
I've never heard anything like it.
You, they are very rich
orchestrations of these,
of the bare bones of these
things and they include a lot
of substitute chords that aren't the
1, 4, 5 kind of thing that we have,
though harmonies are much built
not just on a triad but on the 9th,
11th, and the 13ths
and the presentation
of it is very chamber-like.
Are those accurate
characterizations?
>> Jayme Stone: Totally accurate.
>> Todd Harvey: So
that's intentional?
>> Jayme Stone: Yeah.
I mean that's a big part of our
esthetic language in a lot of ways.
I mean, most well, a lot of folk
music is very chambery, you know,
I mean chamber comes the word
"room" and you know a lot
of old time musicians are making
music in a room, you know,
singing in room filling a hall
with you know a shape note hymn.
You know, calling in spaces,
call and response you know,
when I see those films
of the Georgia Sea Island
Singers they're very much alive
in a room making music in
the space, the music changes
when the space changes,
all of those things.
Of course, we have been influenced
by playing chamber as keynote.
We mentioned this project that
I did, Joe plays in a symphony,
Sumaia was classically trained,
Moira sang early music, you know,
in college and still
continues to do work.
She can sing opera and all kinds of
stuff, so we share that experience
and for me it's chamber music is
so much about color, dynamics,
depth like arch you know how
to build and develop something
over a longer period of time.
How to sort of you know use
all of the colors available
in an instrument and combine them
with all the other instruments
and voices and that's become
for me just the hallmark
of you know interesting
music-making.
So, like I said, things
don't go away.
So not matter what kind of music I
play it's hard not to pay attention
to the arch of an arrangement, to
you know the harmonic possibilities
that are you know maybe
suggested by a melody.
And yeah, I think as modern players
it's our you know our blessing
and our curse to be re-harmonizing
things which is, you know,
to sort of re-contextualize things,
but I mean that's what you know
it's a way of putting a new shine
or you know putting a painting
in a frame to take an old ballad
and then kind of recast it
in this new harmonic space.
It makes you hear the same melody
in a completely different way,
and for me the preservation
work has been done.
I mean, that's what Alan
Lomax and all of the people
that have collected and hear,
I feel like I can't touch them.
You know, like there's
nothing that one needs
to do Jess Morris's "Old Paint."
You know, go listen to it it's like
so incredible and it still sounds
as vibrant as the day it was made,
and so there's no need for me
to recreate that because it's,
it was created and it's there
and I go back and listen
to it all the time.
So, for me what's interesting is
to use my own voice
and what's interesting.
>> Todd Harvey: Right, and
Moira had said she called
"Sylvia" a great sturdy
song and I like that image,
because sometimes we have this
idea that oh it's too delicate
to mess with, you know,
we don't want to a,
we don't want to change
these arrangements.
We don't want to ruin the brand, but
I like that they are sturdy songs,
they can withstand a lot.
>> Jayme Stone: Yeah, and you
know the other thing about it is,
it's not like the recordings
that were captured were somehow,
you know, they're not like the
platonic ideal of a folk song.
You know, there is
no like John Henry.
You know, the one that appears
in a songbook is often one
that never even got played.
It's just cobbled together from
a bunch of different versions
and everybody has their, you
know, somebody blows through town
and a local musician hears
it, it's not on record,
they remember a few words and you
know as Tim O'Brien likes to say
like yeah I couldn't
understand some of the words
so I just made up new ones.
And that's you know, that's the folk
process right there, and you know,
we found, we spent the afternoon
at the Smithsonian Folkways
[inaudible] yesterday
and there was a beautiful
ballad sung by Herald Barker
and I found it so interesting.
I was like wow this sounds so
different and Moira was like,
yeah that's because he
mixed up two ballads.
So, he sang the versus from
one with the chorus of another
and it actually was
really fascinating.
I was like we should do that.
That's really cool,
it sounds different.
And you know, often times these
crooked tunes were just how somebody
heard it or you know how you
know they might have been feeling
on that particular day, and then
we hold them up as being sort
of ideals you know this is what
Stephen Wade talks so beautifully
about in his book, "The Beautiful
Music All Around Us" which was
such a big influence
on this project.
You know, that it's these singular
people that have put their own stamp
on this music and it's the tradition
and it's those two things kind
of that really are the tradition
that are working off each other.
>> Todd Harvey: You talked us
through the arrangement
of "Goodbye Old Paint."
I wonder if you could just
talk a little bit about "I want
to Hear Somebody Pray" is
that the name of that one?
I was very struck by
that and how did you get,
arrive where you are now
with that particular song?
>> Jayme Stone: Yeah, because
it's even different now
than it was on the record.
That song, well Bruce Molsky
who's an amazing old-time musician
who was part of the Lomax
Project in the early days,
and he played me the
Carriacou Lomax record
and I fell in love with that song.
He had actually been to Carriacou
on vacation and met a few
of the musicians and thought he
discovered this whole new musical
culture and you know I remember
he said it was like in the 80s,
he was disappointed to find out
that Lomax had already been there
and recorded all these people.
And so we actually at concerts
started just singing "I Want
to Hear Somebody Pray", clapping,
singing, getting the audience
to sing it just as a little acapella
you know way to finish the show,
and then the night before we
recorded the Lomax Project album,
it was like the night
before the last session,
I was like I really want to do that
tune, but you know I don't want
to just go and sing it
around one microphone.
You know, we had done some other
stuff like that and it sounds,
there's a sort of polyrhythmic myth
in the way the clapping relates
to the singing and it sounds
very you know it's Caribbean,
but it sounds very African and
so I put this piece of foam next
to the banjo bridge that
sort of mutes it in a way
that makes it sound like a gourd
banjo or almost like a tambura
and I just wrote this
whole like kind
of like African sounding banjo
part to go with the melody.
And I was, and I just texted
a little recording of it
to Tim O'Brien and I was
like, what of doing this?
He's like yeah, sounds
great; like tomorrow.
He's like yeah.
So, we all went in, on way to
the studio I don't usually text
and drive, but I was like I knew
that I wanted percussion on it
and there was no percussion
on that session at all.
And so I called my friend
Owen Robinson and I was like,
are you free for a
recording session?
He's like yeah great when.
I'm like 10 minutes.
He was like I'm there.
So he setup, we were
all in one room.
I basically talked through
this idea of the arrangement.
We played it like 3 times and
that's what's on the record.
And now what you're hearing
is that having been seasoned
over a few years now, Moira
brings this whole kind
of improvisational thing.
We would start just free improvising
on the way out at the end
and then eventually it just
organically at concerts
that would kind of cross-fade
with bringing back just the
singing unaccompanied sort
of full circle back to the original
arrangement and it's always sort
of changing, but that's
how that happened.
>> Todd Harvey: That's nice
and when there are sections
that I can see there's
a little improvisation
in your performance
today, and in that kind
of space you do this there a little
scaler passages [singing] kind
of it's not arpeggiated like you
would hear with you know some banjo
and I wonder if that's
one of those signals
that we're vamping right now.
>> Jayme Stone: It's a
thing that I do a lot.
I, another influence
that we didn't talk
about earlier was Steve Reich's
music and I've, you know,
I head music [inaudible]
musicians like a few years
after I started playing banjo
and like completely flipped out.
And there's something that feels so
relatable, because it's a lot of.
>> Todd Harvey: Could you do
like, like Old Paint phase?
>> Jayme Stone: Right.
>> Todd Harvey: You
know where you record it
and then just slightly slow it down/
>> Jayme Stone: Yeah.
We could. Should we do it?
>> Todd Harvey: Yeah.
>> Jayme Stone: After this?
>> Todd Harvey: Let's try it.
>> Jayme Stone: Cool.
>> Todd Harvey: I mean you're
already mixing the media right?
>> Jayme Stone: Do you know
where we could find some reel
to reels around here?
>> Todd Harvey: Yes.
Yes, we can do it.
>> Jayme Stone: Okay great.
>> Todd Harvey: Okay.
>> Jayme Stone: Okay.
Our performance is
going to be next week.
>> Todd Harvey: I feel like this
is a good point to thank you
and to move to any
questions with the audience
and so I've hogged
all of the questions.
Any questions that our
audience members might have
and I'm seeing a few now.
>> Thank you.
I'd love to hear about
your experience
in the archives, how it went about?
What it physically was like?
Todd might have helped
you out a little bit.
Where did you go?
What's the material like?
>> Jayme Stone: Well,
the first time I came,
so I was a little bit rebellious
in school and I never went
to university and I've always
been like very curious in studios,
but not good with institutional
learning you could say.
And so, you know, I showed up here
without a library card having no
idea what the rules or credentials
that were needed or whatever.
I had written Todd earlier to
let him know about the project
and the idea, and also
by the way, I'm on tour.
I give my band lunch money and I was
like, okay you guys go for lunch.
We've got like 3 hours before
we have to you know drive
to the next city and so I showed
up and you were very generous, not.
>> Todd Harvey: Surprised.
>> Jayme Stone: Maybe you were
just in a good mood that day,
but it was pretty clear that
you know there wasn't the time
to you know put on the white gloves
and look for things and write it all
down and wait for it to come up,
so Todd just said let's
just go downstairs.
So, literally within 5 minutes
of being here for the first time,
we were walking around with a
shopping cart through the archives.
Am I allowed to say this out loud?
>> Todd Harvey: Well, we're not
selling anything just be clear
about that.
>> Jayme Stone: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And literally pulling
stuff off of shelves.
I remember there was like an
odd shaped box that was bigger
than the rest, so of course
I was interested in it.
>> Todd Harvey: And I
was like what's that?
>> Jayme Stone: And I remember you
said, oh yeah you should take that.
It was all the letters that
Woody Guthrie had ever sent
to the Lomax family
and then, you know,
I remember even seeing
the Ampex suitcase model,
the first stereo recorder
that Lomax had used
on this whole southern journey
and I, you know, we kind of peered
in the box and I recognized
it from the picture.
There's this great picture of him
with Wade Ward where Wade's smiling
with a few teeth missing, listening
on headphones like probably
for the first time like hearing
himself being played back
and you know, yeah like you
talk about physically, you know,
I am someone that very much
lives in their imagination
and to be quite honest like a
lot of these characters even
when I had read the Lomax
biography, you know,
they were kind of fanciful stories.
And it actually wasn't until I
was here there in the basement
where it was like, I remember
holding the first acetate disc
that Lead Belly ever recorded,
and you know seeing the John Lomax's
beautiful handwriting jotting
down notes, you know, good
guitar playing and you know notes
on desk jackets of like who else
in the county they should go visit
and this kind of thing, and it hit
me like wow these were real people
that had their lives at this
intersection of, you know,
whatever was happening for them,
the music, you know, politics,
race relations, like there were
so many things that were all kind
of in the air as this
work was getting done
and everybody was trying
to figure out how to do it,
how to make a living at it, you
know, and it was so something
about it like it kind of brought
me down to earth in a lot of ways.
And the Lomax Project comes with
like 60 pages of liner notes
and photographs, because it became
really important to me to like think
about where these songs come from
and how they ended
up where they are.
Yeah.
>> Todd Harvey: Well, I think
then we can, we can adjourn.
I'd like to, excuse me, I'd
like to thank Theo Austin
for setting this up.
I'd like to thank our friends
from ITS for making the recording
for all the folks who were able
to make it here in person and all
of you who are watching
on the web streaming,
and most of all, thank
you Jayme Stone.
>> Jayme Stone: Oh, thank you.
It's a real pleasure
and honor to be here.
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.